I have a question for you specifically
okay I didn't apply to you but did you
like as a kid have a sense of like oh I
kind of like this whole like Japanese
culture thing whenever it propped up you
know in like TV or anything I mean to me
was less of a less exotic cuz to me it
was like Asian culture I guess yeah yeah
yeah because it was it was I had seen
more of it because I you know I didn't
exactly grow up in Thailand but I would
visit there at least once a year right
so I spend like my summer holidays in
Thailand every year so seeing some of
the more Japanese culture the more Asian
oriented culture it's not that different
from what you get from flying Asia
my Japanese specific like say onigiri I
didn't have no idea what the five before
but I could see that all it was just a
ball of rice I know Ric is I can see
what this is I guess it's a difference
of me coming from you know the whitest
place on earth and not not being exposed
to any other especially Asian cultures
you know yeah yeah the only Asian
exposure I had you know apart from media
it was just like the shitty Chinese shot
that you know down the road like we've
had awful Chinese and so I think
whenever I saw Japanese stuff in media I
thought so cool like I it's gonna sound
so [ __ ] dumb that would go on you
know if you're more like jackass the
movie or whatever well they wear like
one of them goes to Japan oh yeah sounds
like just stripping in a store and
dancing yeah yeah the whole time I just
ignored dancing look at those [ __ ]
appliances they had I thought it was so
cool they had all these appliances in
the store like I've never seen them like
because in the West we never got those
like TV and radio built in yes and like
they had like the numbers on the side I
thought those were cool as [ __ ] as a kid
and then obviously watching like samurai
stuff and then Samurai Jack was a huge
thing that made me think like I [ __ ]
love samurais yeah oh yeah they were
like the coolest things to me I think I
think it was either like depending on if
you were into anime oh yeah like the two
things that got people into samurai were
at the samurai jack all the while I can
still watch Samurai Jack today and like
[ __ ] love everything my jaw cried
like a baby how my jock is just a
[ __ ] great show it was like the one
concert Network show other than in an
eddy that my dad would be just as
excited to watch was a joke it was like
dude I remember like the episode would
like the assassin do you remember this
one with the like the D at the robot
doll
love that episode that's all my
favorites but uh I think in my head
looking back now I feel like it was
inevitable that I was gonna get into
anime cuz I had like a fondness for
Japanese culture it wasn't like intense
a we be anything I like the movies I
like the like all the culture that I saw
I loved video games and it being a video
game fan you're gonna run into like
stuff so you're like huh why is it like
this and you're like oh it's Japanese
yeah and then also watching anime from a
young age and like yeah so I felt like
it was inevitable at some point in my
life I was gonna find anime and be like
I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] yeah I feel I
completely forgot about video games and
just like JRPGs all roads it's a big
push you don't realize how much really
exactly and I realize a lot of the same
story tropes that drew me to anime like
I liked in JRPGs to JRPGs as well I
guess
remember the time when Japan just fell
like this foreign oh yeah concept oh
wait yeah like this was where this is
way past even when me discovering anime
but I mean I remember like after
discovering anime and start discovering
Naruto and everything you know it was so
weird to find anyone who went to Japan
or see any kind of like Japanese media
even outside of the Japan I feel like
it's only recently become a tourist
destination yeah yeah you know like like
if my my parents who like never want to
leave Europe right like they're like if
it's not Europe it's not a vacation if
they're considering like Oh
career and Japan sounds cool like if
they don't like that I'm like okay well
now I guess everyone's up to it now are
they thinking that yeah they were
planning they're not just cuz I lived
here but they were gonna they wanted to
come out anyway and yeah I feel like
there's that kind of mainstream las' of
it anyway as really like had a big
impact recently cuz I remember when I
first started watching stuff on YouTube
there was no like vloggers like I've
been watching like a Chris broad video
from like years ago yeah and he was like
the only guy right he was one of the oh
geez right like the thing yeah and I
remember back then like if you wanted to
find certain Japanese they were had to
be like a BBC documentary yeah yeah
someone going back right yeah like it
was not a YouTube the weird wacky world
of Japan ya know like you can find out
anything you born about exactly like
it's not hard but I remember yeah like
same thing like you'd see you see these
weird commercials
you'd see like these clips from these
talk show
or the variety shows yeah and you're
like what the [ __ ] is going on in this
country